le conseil départemental de la réunion
vous présente lien social le conseil
départemental aux côtés des réunionnais
la société tout entière est interpellé
par ce fléau universel qu'est la
violence faite aux femmes et aux enfants
et chiffres parlent d'eux même si
réunionnaises ont perdu la vie en 2014
sous les coups de leur compagnon
plus de 39 milles réunionnaise déclare
avoir fait l'objet d'un harcèlement ou
d' insulte soit 20 % des réunionnais
comment tenter de vaincre ces violences
et quelles sont les aides mises en place
on en parle tout de suite dans lien
social le département depuis plusieurs
années a mis en place un plan d'action
commun avec l'état pour lutter contre ce
fléau social
cette violence est le constat d'échec de
la parole il faut restaurer la confiance
du langage des uns envers les autres
il est donc indispensable de mobiliser
les moyens nécessaires pour renforcer
les dispositifs des gouttes de mettre à
l'abri dans l'immédiateté d'aider
d'accompagner en s'appuyant sur le
réseau associatif acteurs directs de ce
dispositif
sandra molly waro assistante sociale au
département est mise à disposition des
services de police et de gendarmerie
pour recueillir et orienter les victimes
de violences conjugales quand elle
arrive au niveau de la police ou de la
gendarmerie elles ne sont augmentés
directement par les policiers par les
gendarmes mais aussi par d'autres
services sociaux où elles viennent me
voir de façon spontanée directement
quand je les rencontre
je vois avec elle d'abord celle ont déjà
porté plainte
sinon je les oriente vers le service des
plaintes et si elles ont déjà porté
plainte
je leur explique en fait la procédure et
je vois surtout au niveau de leurs
droits je fais une évaluation de leur
situation et en fonction de leur
problématique je les oriente vers
d'autres organismes comme le tribunal
comme d'autres services sociaux comme
des services médico-psychologiques je
suis amené à les accompagner à les
suivre tout au long effectivement du
temps de la procédure pénale c'est très
important parce qu'en fait c'est là où
elles se sentent le plus perdu
c'est là où elles ont besoin de plus de
soutien et j'aborde notamment les
mesures de protection
par mesure de protection on peut citer
l'éviction du conjoint du domicile
familial qui peut être prononcée par le
procureur de la république
on peut aussi parler de la revenance de
protection judiciaire qui peut être
sollicitée avec le juge des affaires
familiales et il y a aussi les mises à
l'abri par le biais de structures
d'accueil au niveau du 115 nous sommes
quatre assistantes sociales
réunion et nous oeuvrons effectivement
aux côtés des forces de l'ordre dans la
protection des victimes de violences
conjugales ou intrafamiliales apporter
des solutions immédiates en cas
d'urgence comme par exemple le transport
par les taxiteurs ou la mise à l'abri
dans le cadre d'un hébergement font
partie des services mise en place par la
collectivité que nathalie and be nous
décrit l'attractivité mal une politique
volontariste et ambitieuse plusieurs
années voire même depuis plus de dix ans
puisque l'institution alain stritt comme
un axe fort de sa politique
d'accompagnement de ses victimes
plusieurs actions donc dans le cadre de
l'accompagnement de ce public vous avez
un premier niveau qui est celui de la
mise à l'abri des femmes victimes de
violences et de leurs enfants soit dans
les centres d'hébergement d'urgence que
nous confie dans son côté de l'état soit
dans le cadre d'une d'un hébergement de
les structures d'accueil les hôtels
pensions de famille et gic quand il n'y
a plus place dans les centres
d'hébergement d'urgence pour faciliter
la mise à l'abri de ces femmes la
collectivité co finance également des
taxiteurs qui garantissent une mise à
l'abri rapide de ses victimes
le deuxième temps fort c'est celui de
l'accompagnement des associations à la
fois pour écouter accompagner les
victimes mais également parfois pour
accompagner les docteurs puisque
l'action en direction des violences
intrafamiliales si on veut qu'elle soit
efficace il faut qu'elle intervienne à
deux niveaux celui des victimes bien
évidemment mais également celui de
l'accompagnement des auteurs et le
troisième point qui est mis en place
depuis quelques années c'est celui des
assistantes sociales en police et
gendarmerie où là on est sur une action
en partenariat avec l'état pour
justement faciliter le dépôt de plainte
faciliter l'accompagnement et d' écoute
des femmes victimes de violence donc
dans les services de police et de
gendarmerie on en a quatre
à ce jour deux dans les services de
police et deux dans les services de
gendarmerie
une action complémentaire à celui aura
celle de l'hébergement d'urgence c'est
que la collectivité dans le cadre de sa
mission de protection de l'enfance
finances des relais familiaux qui sont
des structures qui accueillent donc des
cinq victimes de violence avec les
enfants mais dans un projet
d'accompagnement ceux du plus long terme
notamment pour faciliter ensuite la
station socialisation professionnelle et
donc inciter la femme a poursuit sa
démarche de se séparer de son conjoint
violent
j'étais victime de la violence conjugale
et pour moi c'était très dur au début de
surmonter tout ça et j'ai appelé le
membre de ma famille soit on au parent
qui va puer des dents au niveau moral
est haut je suis retourné à la réunion
pour être l'idée par la famille en fait
ça m'a aidé à évoluer tout le monde toi
de moi en fait qui m'ont aidé à avancer
dans l'avion une structure c'est le
foyer rose des bois qui que j'étais bien
j'étais chez eux et c'est grâce aux
chefs de service qui m'a aidé tout au
long de mon séjour chez eux en fait et
après le 115 qui ont pu être hébergés
dans un structure de substantielles et
ensuite j'ai été redirigés vers
saint-denis enfin sur le rôle des femmes
il ya deux ans quand j'ai été victime de
violences conjugales j'ai pas appelé la
police en fait parce que j'ai aimé la
personne en fait jusqu'à quand le joueur
ça clashe et là j'ai pris la décision de
déposer plainte et appelé la police mais
moi je dis aux personnes qui sont
victimes des violences ne pas baisser
les bras en fait si une personne
commencé à four vous commencent à
frapper une fois d'arrêter et de surtout
ne pas hésiter de déposer peur quand une
fois on pose la masse deuxième phase
fait au g en fait don jeudi c'est pas
grâce à un homme qu'on peut avancer
au contraire nous sommes seuls avec des
enfants par vance et surmonter la vie à
des milliers de réunionnais en dur
chaque jour ces situations et pour que
cela cesse il faut un véritable
changement de mentalité d'éducation et
la mobilisation de tous ces changements
prendront du temps
la préfecture la région et le
département ont signé ensemble le
dispositif téléphone grand danger
renforcer la protection des femmes
victimes de violence conjugale ou de
viols en très grand danger
soyons tous unis pour mettre fin à ce
genre de comportement sans réserve sans
hésitation et sans délai disons tous
stop à la violence
le conseil départemental de la réunion
vous a présenté lien social
le conseil départemental aux côtés des
réunionnais